clark county school district calls for a
pause to try and slow down a rise in
covet cases now the pause will run
friday through next tuesday this is
cases jumped more than a thousand in
just one day in the school district
eight news now reporter madison
kimbrough joining us now live from park
elementary near downtown las vegas with
how parents are reacting to this
announcement madison
yeah parents i spoke to are not
surprised by this decision at all now
this is going to take place starting on
friday and then last until wednesday
january 19th
schools already have martin luther king
jr day off on monday so this pause is
two additional days out of the classroom
the cancellation comes as ccsd has shown
a surge in the last week with over 2200
cases staff will be required to work
from home on friday and on that tuesday
additionally ccsd is facing extreme
staffing shortages based on the high
number of covet 19 reports the school
district reports the five-day pause will
promote a safe healthy learning
environment in their schools to stop the
spread in order to continue face-to-face
instruction a parent at robert e lake
elementary hopes the cases go down kind
of been an ongoing issue as far as like
you know
even if they sneeze they out five days
you know what i mean like so it's been
kind of a precautious thing but when we
got the email today
it's kind of been a thing where we get
emails all the time about
there's a chance somebody got covered
it's a process like everything else with
this whole pandemic thing but
you know what can we do but try to keep
our kids safe nevada governor steve
sisilak released a statement saying that
while some parents may not be happy with
this decision he is committed to keeping
schools open for in-person learning and
keeping our students educators and staff
safe moving forward ccsd stating that
they hope this long weekend will allow
staff students and hardworking educators
to get healthy so they can return safely
now also close during the pause city of
las vegas reinvent after school program
and safe keep programs now as for
reaction on social media from parents we
heard from a lot of people not happy
about this decision reporting live
madison kimbrough live local now
madison thank you many no doubt concern
if this will lead to other closures the
governor also addressing that directly
saying in part
2022 will not be 2020. we now have the
tools the knowledge and resources to
keep schools open safely and effectively
there is no going back